Imagine you're trying to learn a new language. You're out there having conversations, trying to absorb the natural rhythm, the slang, the messy way people actually talk.
Right. The real world usage.
Exactly. But half the people you're talking to are also students who learn from the exact same textbook as you.
Oh, man.
Right? How long until everyone is just repeating the same weird grammatical quirks, completely losing the actual, I don't know, the soul of the language?
Yeah. The nuance completely flattens out. You end up with this highly predictable, almost sterile dialect because, well, nobody is introducing anything genuinely complex or surprising anymore.
And we are looking at that exact scenario today, but on a massive scale for the future of the Internet and artificial
intelligence. It's a huge shift.
It really is. You told us you were curious about where AI is heading and what happens when models run out of fresh human data. So for today's Deep Dive, we are unpacking a fascinating brand new paper from September 2026.
Fresh off the presses.
Yeah, out of the University of Maryland and Pangram Labs titled, How Much Is an AI Token Worth? Scaling Laws for Wild AI-Generated Web Text.
Which is such a great title because we are looking at a massive blind spot in AI development right now. I mean, the industry knows that language models are essentially eating the Internet to get smarter.
Right. The data crawl.
Exactly. The open question is what physically happens to these models when the Internet they're eating is increasingly made of text written by other models?
Yeah. And before we get into the sheer volume of this, we should probably establish our terms for you listening. The title asks what an AI token is worth. And we'll be talking a lot about parameters, too.
Right. The basics.
So for someone not building these models every day, how should we visualize those two concepts?
So think of a token as the basic unit of currency in an AI's brain. It's usually a chunk of a word, maybe three or four letters. When an AI reads or writes, it processes text token by token.
Okay, got it.
And a parameter, on the other hand, is essentially a synthetic brain connection. It's a mathematical weight inside the model that helps it decide which token should come next based on all the patterns it learned during training.
So like a token is the food and the parameters are the digestive system processing it?
Yeah, that's a really good way to look at it.
And the paper makes a crucial distinction about the specific kind of tokens we're talking about today. Because this isn't about synthetic data generated in some clean room, right?
Oh, that distinction is vital. Synthetic data is usually carefully engineered in a lab for a very specific task. Like you might prompt a powerful model to write thousands of step-by-step math solutions to train a smaller model in logic.
Like a textbook.
Exactly. But this paper is looking at wild AI text.
Wild text.
Yeah, this is text written by dozens of different language models, chatbots, automated bloggers, marketing tools, and it's meant for human readers. It gets published on the web, and crucially, it gets scooped up completely unlabeled in those massive web crawls that tech companies
use.
Right, it just blends in.
And to understand the scale of this wild AI text, the authors actually took a specialized tool, the Pangram 3.3.2 detector, and ran it over a sample of 310,000 web documents.
Massive sample.
Massive.
And they charted the data from 2021 to 2026. The shift is just staggering. Back in 2021, AI-generated tokens made up less than 0.1% of the filtered web.
Basically nothing.
Basically nothing. By June of 2024, it hit 10%. June 2025, 16%. And by August of 2026, the paper says 31.1% of the web text they analyzed was machine-generated.
Yeah, and if you follow that trajectory, the authors forecast that by the end of 2028, half of the text scraped from the internet will be written by machines.
Half. That's wild. But this machine text isn't just like a fine layer of dust covering the whole internet evenly, right? It's pooling in very specific places.
Right, it's highly concentrated.
Yeah, I'm looking at the breakdown here, and the format concentration is nuts. Tutorials, for example, make up 18.5% of all AI tokens, but only 6.2% of human tokens.
Which makes total sense based on financial incentives.
Because of the SEO-optimized content.
Exactly. People use AI to mass-produce content that answers search queries like how-to guides or listicles. But you know what's interesting? Personal blogs have basically vanished from the AI-generated pool.
Because nobody is using an AI to write a diary entry.
Right. But the most alarming finding in this first half of the paper isn't just the sheer volume of AI text. It's how the industry's own tools are actively accelerating its dominance.
Oh, you're talking about the quality filters. This completely threw me when I read it. Because you would assume tech companies use massive filters to scrub out this machine-generated noise, right?
Yeah, you'd think they'd want pure data.
Exactly. Before feeding it to their new models.
They do use filters, but the paper reveals those standard quality filters actually prefer AI text over human text.
Wait, really?
Yeah. The researchers tested this on two major data pipelines. When you run a raw web crawl through the fine web quality filters, AI documents survive 2.3 times as often as human ones.
2.3 times? That is...
And it gets worse. In a different pipeline called DCLM, AI documents pass the filters an astonishing 9.8 times as often as human documents.
Wait, how is an objective filter for good writing actively throwing out human writing? What is the actual mechanism inside the filter that makes it prefer a machine?
Well, it comes down to how we've mathematically defined quality. I mean, a filtering algorithm doesn't understand meaning or soul or creativity.
Right, it's just math.
Right. It runs statistical checks. It looks for predictable n-gram probabilities, meaning like, do these specific words commonly appear together? It checks for consistent paragraph lengths, perfect spelling, and low perplexity, which is a metric for how unsurprising
the text is.
Oh, I see. And because language models are literally just prediction engines, they naturally generate text with extremely low perplexity.
Exactly. They use the most statistically probable words in pristine grammatical structures.
Which the algorithm sees as a signal of high quality, while human writing is, well, incredibly messy.
Exactly. We use weird slang. We break grammar rules for stylistic effect. We go on totally random tangents. We have high perplexity.
So the filter looks at those human quirks, flags them as low-quality spam, and strips them out of the training data.
Yeah.
It's like a spelling bee judge who only counts perfect punctuation marks and totally ignores the fact that the essay itself is entirely hollow.
That is a perfect analogy.
So if these filters are serving up a massive, highly concentrated buffet of AI text, what physically happens to the models that are forced to train on it?
Well, to answer that, the paper moves into a massive pre-training experiment. The authors built 800 different language models from scratch, ranging from tiny 19.9 million parameter models up to nearly a billion parameters.
Wow, 800 models?
Yeah, using a nano-chat architecture. They took a fixed amount of human text and started adding wild AI tokens to it, adding up to 64 AI tokens for every single human token.
Okay, so I remember reading a while back that if an AI just trains on its own garbage over and over, it essentially goes crazy and starts spitting out gibberish. Is that what we're seeing here?
Ah, you're referring to the concept of model collapse. That was famously detailed in a 2024 Nature paper by Shumailov and his colleagues.
Right, Shumailov, yes.
Yeah. They showed that if you trap a model in a recursive closed loop, like training it on its own generated output repeatedly, it eventually erases the tails of the data distribution.
It forgets the rare stuff.
Exactly. It forgets the rare, complex information and collapses into generating nonsense. But this 2026 paper is testing something very different.
Because it's not a closed loop in a lab?
Correct. This is the Wild Web. The text comes from many different models interacting in complex ways originally generated for human readers. It's a much more subtle contamination.
But even with wild data, I thought the consensus was that this wasn't a fatal problem. Like, wasn't there a study a couple of years ago arguing that as long as you keep feeding a model real, fresh human data alongside the synthetic data, it balances out?
Yes, that was a prominent reassurance from Gerstgrasser and colleagues in 2024. They argued that accumulating real data prevents collapse, even if synthetic data is present. But this new experiment completely shatters that reassurance. The authors measured
the loss of these 800 models.
And loss is basically the penalty score, right?
Yeah, it's the mathematical penalty a model pays when it fails to accurately predict the next word on a test of purely held-out human text. A lower loss means a smarter model.
And what did the loss reveal about the AI tokens?
The core result of the paper is that AI text only helps what we call data-starved models. If a model is very small relative to the amount of data it has seen, specifically if it has seen less than 10 human tokens per parameter, then throwing AI text at it
lowers the loss.
So it helps it learn the basics.
Exactly.
But 10 tokens per parameter is just the warm-up phase, right? The industry standard for training a model optimally is usually around 20 human tokens per parameter.
And that is the exact threshold where the disaster starts. Once a model hits that optimal 20 tokens per parameter, adding wild AI tech starts to actively raise the loss.
Wait, so it makes the model dumber?
Yes. It mathematically degrades the model's ability to understand human text. Meanwhile, if you took that same well-trained model and added fresh human text instead, the loss would keep going down. The mathematical value of an AI token doesn't just plateau. It literally goes
negative.
That's incredible. Consider the mechanism there. It's almost like eating junk food.
Okay, how so?
Well, if you're starving, like a data-starved model, a candy bar provides basic caloric value. It keeps you alive and teaches your body how to process sugar. But if you're a peak performance athlete eating a perfectly balanced diet,
adding 10 candy bars to your routine doesn't just do nothing.
Right. It hurts you.
Exactly. The empty calories actively degrade your athletic performance.
That's exactly what's happening. The early AI tokens provide the empty calories of basic grammar and structure, but they completely lack the complex nutrition of rare vocabulary and novel ideas found in human text.
So once the model masters the easy stuff, the AI text just dilutes the training pool.
Precisely. It pulls the model's internal weights away from the true, messy distribution of human language.
But wait, these multi-billion dollar tech companies have armies of engineers mapping out the physics of AI training. How did they not see this negative value coming? Don't they have mathematical laws governing how much data a model needs?
They do, but those laws were written for a purely human internet. The foundational theory of AI training comes from a landmark 2022 paper by Hoffman and colleagues.
Ah, the Chinchilla scaling laws.
universally known as chinchilla, yes. The chinchilla paper established that optimal training happens around that 20 tokens per parameter mark. But it has a fatal assumption for the modern web.
Which is?
It treats every single token exactly alike.
Oh, it assumes a token is a token, regardless of who wrote it.
Yes. Chinchilla predicts that throwing more text at a model will continually decrease the loss forever. When applied to a data set filled with wild AI text, the Chinchilla law gets the direction entirely wrong. It predicts improvement where there is actually
degradation.
But haven't we known for a while that not all data is equally valuable? For instance, I recall Munninghoff and colleagues mapped out in a 2023 paper that if you just feed a model the exact same text repeatedly, it stops learning.
Yes, exactly. Munninghoff proved, mathematically, that repeated tokens are worth less than fresh ones. But his rule established a floor. He claimed the value of a repeated token never drops below zero. It might stop helping, but it won't cause harm.
And this 2026 paper breaks that floor entirely?
Completely. Because an AI token isn't just a repeated human thought. It's a computationally hollow thought. It can be worth less than nothing. So the authors of this new paper actually had to write a brand new scaling law.
Wow. They rewrote the physics.
Yeah. They kept the backbone of the chinchilla formula, but they added two new mathematical terms to account for the machine text.
How did those new terms physically change the calculation?
Well, the first is a saturating benefit term. This accounts for the candy bar phase you mentioned, where the AI text initially gives the model a quick boost in basic grammar, but quickly maxes out and offers zero additional nutritional value.
And the second term?
The second is a harm term that grows logarithmically.
Meaning the harm isn't just a flat penalty. It steadily compounds as the model consumes larger and larger volumes of AI text.
Exactly. And the elegance of their new formula is that if you set the volume of AI text to zero, the math seamlessly reduces right back to the original chinchilla law.
That is elegant.
And when they tested this new law on their largest held-out models, the 477 million and 973 million parameter runs, it was vastly more accurate.
How much more accurate?
The new formula predicted the model's performance on the C4 text with a paired error of just 0.83%. Wow. Yeah. Compare that to a 1.41% error for the best existing law by Shakur or a massive 4.32% error if
you tried to rely on chinchilla.
This entirely changes the game. It reminds me of a theory proposed back in 2024 by Domotov and colleagues in a paper called A Tale of Tales.
Yes.
They theorized that introducing synthetic data wouldn't just shift the model's performance slightly, but would fundamentally alter the underlying scaling laws themselves.
This new paper is essentially the empirical web-scale confirmation of Domotop's theory. We now have hard proof, validated across hundreds of models, that an internet heavily polluted with wild AI text requires a completely different set of physical laws to
navigate.
Which brings us to a massive practical dilemma. I mean, these companies test their models constantly. If AI techs is actively harming a well-trained model's ability to understand language, why aren't the validation dashboards lighting up red inside these tech companies?
Oh, this is the scariest part. The paper exposes a deeply insidious problem called the validation trap. Developers test their models on validation sets, basically a final exam the model takes to prove how smart it is before it gets released.
Okay, sure.
But what happens if the exam itself is contaminated?
Because the validation sets are scraped from the same web as the training data. So they must be full of AI text too.
Exactly. The researchers analyzed their 2026 evaluation crawl and found the validation set itself contained a 22.3% AI share. And here is the mechanism of the trap. Because AI text is so structurally
pristine and predictable, it is mathematically much easier for a language model to guess the next token.
Ah. So it's an exam filled with painfully easy questions.
Yes. The presence of that easy AI text in the validation set successfully hid the active harm being done to the model in 95.5% of the harmful
runs. 95.5%? Yeah.
The dashboard shows a lowering loss score, leading engineers to believe the model is improving, when in reality, its ability to comprehend complex human written text is actively degrading.
That is a terrifying blind spot for any company spending billions of dollars on compute clusters. Because training these models isn't cheap. And fighting through this negative value must come with a physical cost.
Oh, the compute tax is staggering. The authors calculate that if a developer trains a model on a raw, unfiltered web crawl at today's 31% AI share, it costs about 1.6 times the compute power to achieve the same performance as if they had just trained on the
pure human subset of that data.
They are burning 60% more electricity in silicon just to process actively harmful noise.
And by 2028, when the AI share is forecast to hit 50%, that compute tax rises to about three times. You will need triple the supercomputers just to fight through the garbage and reach the same level of intelligence.
So if you are a developer today and you've literally exhausted all the fresh human text on the Internet, what is the mathematically sound move?
The paper offers a highly counterintuitive answer based on their new scaling law. You are better off just repeating the human text you already have. Even with the diminishing returns Muninghoff warned about, looping high-quality human data is mathematically
superior to adding fresh, unique, AI-generated text.
Just read the same brilliant books twice rather than reading a billion mediocre machine-written blog posts.
Right. Unless, ironically, your goal is to build a machine that only talks to other machines. The researchers found that if your target is specifically to generate AI text, then the optimal training mix is actually over 90% AI text.
Okay, let's pause and push back on this for a second, because we do have to name the structural limitations of a study this bold. First, scale. This experiment tops out at models just under a billion parameters. Frontier models today are
hundreds of times larger than that. Could massive scale change how a model compartmentalizes this data?
It definitely could.
Second, we are talking about loss, which is a proxy for predicting a hidden word. It's not a direct measurement of downstream capability, like whether the model can code a website or write a compelling story.
Both of those limitations are vital context. Scale is the great wildcard in AI. A trillion-parameter model might have enough internal capacity to recognize the structural patterns of AI text and isolate them, preventing them from overriding its complex human knowledge.
And you're right, mathematical loss doesn't perfectly map to real-world usefulness.
And crucially, we really have to point out the conflict of interest at the foundation of the methodology here. This paper comes from the University of Maryland and Pangram Labs. They are defining what is and isn't AI text by using Pangram Labs' own
commercial detector.
Yeah, it is a tension that absolutely demands scrutiny. I mean, using an automated detector is the only physical way to measure 310,000 web documents over five years. Human annotation would take a lifetime.
Right. It's necessary.
But it means the entire architectural premise of this paper and all the negative value it calculates rests entirely on the accuracy and the potential blind spots of that specific company's product.
Exactly. But even holding those limitations in mind, the stakes of what they've measured are monumental. If the forecasts hold and half the web is machine written in just a couple of years. and our standard quality filters actively throw away
human text to favor the sterile perfection of a machine, we are fundamentally altering the bedrock of all future technology.
The immediate consequence is scarcity. Human text is rapidly becoming a finite, highly contested resource.
For you listening to this, it totally upends what high-quality information is even going to mean in the future. The old internet, you know, pre-2022 data crawls, licensed historical archives, verified human interactions. Those are about to become
the most valuable commodities in the tech industry. They are the unpolluted reservoirs.
Because once the water supply is mixed, it is mathematically incredibly expensive to filter the synthetic runoff back out.
Which leaves us with a final thought to mull over. If the algorithms that dictate visibility on the internet are increasingly filtering out human quirks, slang, and structural messiness as low quality, what happens to anyone who writes for the
web? Are we approaching a future where human writers, you know, journalists, novelists, or even just you sending an email, have to intentionally start mimicking the sterile, predictable style of an AI just to ensure our voices survive the filters and
actually get read?
The tool we built to mimic our language might ultimately force us to mimic its language.
We might all end up reading from the exact same textbook. Keep questioning the information ecosystem around you. Thanks for diving deep with us.